clark county students have not been in a
classroom in more than seven
months well today the clark county
school board will start discussing plans
to at least partially reopen some
campuses
hector mejia live this morning at
district headquarters with a look ahead
hector good morning
good morning john and that debate
continues today no vote is expected but
all eyes will be on the clark county
school district here
as it tries to sort out how to safely
move forward and many parents want to
know
are we anywhere close to the end of
remote learning at ccsd
the board of trustees is scheduled to
talk about transitioning to a hybrid
plan
at a meeting that's scheduled at five
this evening although it's only up for
discussion and a vote is not expected
until november 12th
parents say well at least this is a
start trustees are also going over
community feedback
it's all part of the first step in
possibly returning teachers and students
back to their classroom
here's one take from a mother about
sending her child back to face to face
instruction
if the parent doesn't feel comfortable
with sending their child to school
that's fine
but if they do they should be able to go
whether they do the hybrid or all five
days in class
it should be left in the parents hands
to send their children to school
the southern nevada health district will
also provide trustees with the latest
coveted numbers
report from the agenda also shows
there's still a higher risk of
transmission in schools based on
information as of monday
and we also talked with a school board
trustee who said the discussions tonight
should focus on more than just
a transition plan i'll have that still
ahead in the next half hour reporting
live outside ccsd headquarters hector
mejia
8 news now